fascinating piece in the mm QB by Robert
Clem Co entitled what does Cuyler Murray
really want he's joining us here now on
the Rich Eisen show how are you Robert
I'm doing great how are you guys I'm
great so I mean this is a fascinating
piece to me Robert for many reasons
because you do such a deep dive and you
clearly are excellent what you do and
you put what you normally do to work for
a fascinating conversation involving the
first overall selection and what it
might mean for the entire NFL drafting
someone of his physical stature first
overall but the fact that what does
Kyler Murray really want is it really a
question in the NFL or the NFL Scouting
or evaluation community that he's not
all in on football at this point in time
you know I think it is a question but
not in the sense that he's going to not
like his draft position and then go play
baseball instead and and and hurt some
team that way I think the question is
you know if he gets picked by the
Cardinals or one of these teams in the
top five that is probably gonna struggle
his rookie year he gets thrown in there
and he gets sacks 50 60 times and it
goes that way for two or three years and
he gets hurt or he's not playing well
then he's got the best parachute of
anybody in the NFL
he's got Major League Baseball and so
the question is not whether calimary is
gonna go play baseball in 2019 its
whether he's gonna go play baseball in
2022 and so you think that might be in
the mind's eye of the Arizona Cardinals
over the next six days Robert you know I
think Kliff Kingsbury has enough of a
relationship with the family and with
them you know with the agent I mean they
share an agent in Eric Burkhart over at
select Sports Group I think that they're
close enough that Kingsbury has
confidence you know if they are gonna
make this pick it will be because
Kingsbury has confidence that Kyler
Murray that's not his intention you know
growing up for this kid it was all about
football baseball was kind of a back-up
plan because he was short and he did get
to high school and he was a five foot
eight 5 foot nine quarterback so he
played baseball when he wasn't playing
football
so you know I never wanted to give the
impression with the story that it was
5050 with him I think that he was just
waiting to hear from NFL people that
they believed he could actually do this
and then when he heard that he was all
in on football and it's interesting part
of your pieces as well is that the A's
did something unprecedented to try and
keep him from choosing this route would
you explain to those who might not have
heard about it or read it through your
piece Robert yeah the A's were willing
to put him on the 40-man roster you know
even though he wouldn't have been on the
team and he would have played triple-a
ball the A's were willing to give him 14
million dollars to not play in the NFL
to not declare for the draft and to just
go to spring training and that's kind of
crazy for a guy who had you know just
one really good season of college
baseball at OU you I think that there
was an element in this whole baseball
versus football struggle of baseball
wanting to get a PR win and that's why
you know when they had the meeting in
Dallas in January when they offered him
this 14 million dollar deal they brought
a major league baseball marketing
executive and that person kind of laid
out of how they were going to market him
on a national scale and we're talking
about a guy that you know isn't even a
major league baseball yet and even with
Scott Boras and everything that he said
throughout the process there was this
element of we want to win this war with
football and and calimary was you know a
little bit of a pawn in that game Robert
Klem Cove Sports Illustrated here in the
Rich Eisen show so why did he choose
baseball the football over baseball is
it just simply because he heard that
it's entirely possible he could be
drafted in the first round and then put
two and two together with Kings very
fast once he got the job in Arizona back
in January you know I think that he
wanted to feel like he was wanted and
you know this family of his player they
have extreme confidence in his ability
to thrive but I think they felt that it
had to take a team feeling he was a
franchise quarterback for it to be worth
it for him to go to the NFL because he
could have a long successful baseball
career and you know
potentially make a lot more money with a
lot less injury risk but he loves
playing quarterback and he wanted to be
wanted well personally you know Robert I
think he made this decision before he
even set foot in the Super Bowl in
Atlanta I got that sense from him even
though he before stopping on Dan Patrick
show what you put in your piece stopped
on mine as well we just pre taped it and
aired it later we had the same
experience with him where he didn't
answer a single question about it and we
were left scratching our heads how he
would why he would come to the Super
Bowl without an answer to the question
he knew he was going to get right and
didn't have an answer for it why did why
did that happen why do you think I'd
still love to know what what the hell
happened with him showing up in Super
Bowl week like that Robert yeah you know
you you you watch those interviews and
you hear those stories and you think
okay well he wasn't prepared right and
and but then you talk to people that
were close to the situation and and and
around Super Bowl week and and familiar
with all that that went into it and he
was prepared they had answers and he
just kind of froze and you know I write
about him looking off to his father you
know in in the USA a bank charity thing
where these military families are asking
the same questions I think that he they
don't have a great sense of the media
and they feel like a lot of these
players coming out of college football
big 12 SEC don't understand that they're
gonna be held to a higher level of
scrutiny when they get to a media venue
like Super Bowl week and I think the
other thing is that he hadn't made up
his mind you know they can say now that
they have made up their mind but they
still took the meeting with the a to
talk money he hadn't told his mother
until after Super Bowl week which way he
was going to go so if he had made up his
mind you know that was that was
something that was entirely exclusively
in his head Wow so if he didn't tell his
mom until after the Super Bowl he sure
as heck wasn't telling me or Dan Patrick
we were anybody else Wow
did is I think his dad knew Robert
though I got to be honest with you I got
that sense
on that day you know dad is a that's a
football guy and and I think that and a
baseball guy too I mean it's a it's it's
an interesting family as you point out
in your piece yeah but he was he was
Tyler's individual quarterback coach and
and after Kyler was drafted and by the
Oakland A's they sat down as a family
and kind of talked and dad predicted
you're about to tear it up this season
and you're gonna change the way NFL
folks feel about you and you know around
Super Bowl time was when they really
started getting word that you know he
was definitely going to be a first-round
pick
so before I let you go here Robert two
more questions
what because many people might be
hearing this conversation saying look
you know what that this all may be the
case but he's gonna be drafted first
overall next week
what of everything that you were
reporting on or exposed to from from the
family dynamic to his history to what
you're hearing about Scouts or from
scouts or unnamed and named in your
piece evaluators do you think will
manifest itself in terms of whether he's
successful in the NFL once he starts
playing football in the fall you know I
think that the consensus is he's a guy
who's gonna need a perfect situation and
you know you could say that around any
quarterback drafted anywhere in the
draft but with him you know being 510 I
think there's a very specific kind of
offense and very specific kind of
offensive philosophy that works and
that's why the Kingsbury connection
makes so much sense because the same
thing that Baker Mayfield did I tell you
the same thing Tyler Murray did a toe
you the same thing Kliff Kingsbury has
been coaching for you know the last five
six seven years at the college football
level is what Tyler Murray thrives that
I mean he'll it's the same offense he
ran at Allen high school in Texas so you
know I think people feel like obviously
he needs to be in a system he's
comfortable with to thrive and a coach
that is innovative and understand that
despite everything that you know Kyle
Emery is going to feel and Kyle Emery is
going to say in the press there are
limitations to being five foot ten and
playing quarterback in the NFL and then
the last thing
for you is being around the NFL as you
have been what what do you think is the
story of the non-playing season so far
that everyone else is talking about
outside of the draft that you've been
hearing about or reporting on Robert the
story of the offseason I mean Odell
Beckham and Antonio Brown changing teams
like whenever we ever had skill position
talent like that right change hands in
the NFL in an off season and then the
story today about the Raiders sending
their scouts all time I mean that well
wow I've never I've never heard anything
like that well I mean they do you know
teams do usually tighten the rotation of
Draft week as to who's allowed to see
the draft board and who isn't so the the
the Beckham one and the brown one is
interesting to me because some of the
stuff that I've heard Robert I'm
wondering if you have as well is that
part of the reasons why the Giants did
part ways with him right now is because
they saw what Antonio Brown accomplished
through Instagram with a mr. big chest
and everything else that he was able to
do with some well-timed interviews
national sports stations that once Odell
came through this year and no longer had
guaranteed money on his contract similar
to what Antonio Brown had that they were
concerned he would do the same thing and
they would wind up with the same
compensation that the Steelers wound up
as opposed to what they could get from
Cleveland right here right now what do
you think I think that's very fair and
you know I wasn't down on them for for
allowing him to go
I think another element of it is they
know they're probably gonna pick a
quarterback in the first or second round
in this draft and they didn't feel like
Oh Dell Beckham was the type of player
who was going to Shepherd a new
quarterback
into the mix and help him become a great
Pro and so if you don't have that guy
then I think you start to rebuild your
skill position wise and if that guy is
going to cost you a lot of money and
headache over the next couple of years
then yeah get what you can for them
Robert appreciate the time we'll chat
again soon have a great time with the
draft
thank you at me you got it that's Robert
Clem Coe he can read his peace what does
carla marie really want at the mmq be
calm for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 under red TV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app